My youngest baby is two,
and I am just now feeling like my body is my own again.
And as a third time mom,
I really thought I knew what to expect,
especially when it came to postpartum recovery.
I give myself a lot of Grace and a lot of patience,
but even then,
even with going back and working out,
even with, like,
trying to take care of myself,
it still has taken two years
for me to even feel remotely back to the starting point
I was before I had this third baby.
I don't know if it was the fact that this is my third,
if the fact that I'm in my mid 30s,
or if I just have a lot more going on
than I did when I had my first two kids.
Like, health and fitness kind of went on the back burner
for a little while.
The fact that we tell women
that postpartum is one year is insane,
because I have never felt recovered from a pregnancy
one year out.
So if you are still struggling with feeling like
your body is still kind of a foreign object to you,
just know to give yourself until the two year Mark
and then reevaluate.
Every postpartum is different,
and everybody's body is different.